THE PENGUINS WILL BE WEARING
MAONNS BOARD.
PETTERSSON'S SHIFTY
THE LONG TIME DUCK WITH OVER
1,000 POINTS IN HIS CAREER.
>> Bob: WELL,
JASON,N,DUCKS.
FROMs CERTAINLY NEEDED A
CHANGE AFTER THE EFFORTS OF THAT
SHIFT.
WOW.
RUHWEDEL.
TO THE INSIDE.
HE SCORES! A MINUSCULE.
THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK AT IT AND
THE SPEED BY ZACH ATMOSPHERE TO.
HOLIDAY LINE COMES INTO THE GIB.
UNDER PRESSURE FROM
MAKES THE SAVE ON SILFVERBERG. .
LOOK AT THIS PLAY HERE.
I LOVE THAT SAVE ON SILFVERBERG.
THAT WAS A BLUE LINE.
SHOT OFF BY GIBSON.
DOESN'T KNOW WHERE IT IS.
NOW THEY ROLL OUT WITH THE
WINTER HERE.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE FIVE O GAME.
GETZLAF STILL OUT THERE. BY GIB.
AND THE WHISTLE'S DO
>> Bob: PENGUINS, HARD WORK.
TAKES THE PUCK TO THE NET. MADE.
SCRAMBLE.
HUSTLING
>> Steve: A TOUCH PASS BARELY
HELD IN.
THE
THE LEAD PASS.
BOYLE.
BOYLE LEANS INTO
MATHESON.
STILL ON THE ATTACK.
STOPPED BY GIBSON. MIDDLE.
MILANONO THIS  HAND AND ACROSS
2 FOR 2. WIDE.
CARRY ON THE CLEAR
NONO
OVER TO KAPANEN.USH.
BLOCKED AWAY BY STOLARZ.
ZEGRAS.REBOUND W
DESMITH, HE'S GOT ANOTHER ONE. T
BEHIND DESMITH.